the jurgen experience
and so
you go from this to i mean i don't want
to make this big leap into the jeff
bezos thing but it is um
it's it's very fascinating to me you
were involved in
finding out how jeff bezos's phone got
hacked and you were involved in
connecting it to the saudis and that
whole thing how did this all come about
well i i have promised i wrote one um
op-ed for the daily beast about this and
in that op-ed at the end i say i'll
never say another word on this case
because i'm turning it over to the
federal government now it's a few years
ago so i what i can share is only that
which has been public and a lot wasn't
public but uh
the
the uh
circumstance did involve mbs who's the
prime you know the the prince of saudi
arabia
and he did send a a text with a video to
jeff bezos they knew each other they had
met they had exchanged phone numbers and
embedded in that video was a a
system that
downloaded something that then later
connects to a website and downloads
something more sinister like pegasus 2
which is a a a
system that
governments around the world use to get
into your phone and then they have full
control of your phone so it doesn't
immediately connect it doesn't download
immediately because it's a bigger
package what what you're getting in your
first uh incursion into a phone
uh or laptop or ipad or whatever you're
getting a uh a very small file a little
executable file
that then later reaches out uh via the
internet and that executable file could
be a website it could be
and does it exist only on the physical
phone itself or is it is it in the
operating system and if you change
phones and like upload to the cloud and
then re-upload do you or re-download on
a new phone does that
does that spy software make it onto your
phone again
probably not but we don't know
completely whether it does or it doesn't
when a government wants you like the us
government or saudi or basically there
are there are two kinds of countries in
the world when it comes to uh
to incursions into uh smartphones there
are original developers the united
states china soviet union and israel so
they're original developers of programs
that do these things and then there are
the purchasing countries uh mexico saudi
arabia and all 190 other countries by
the way i say 190 do you know there
isn't even a consensus about the number
of countries in the world countries
can't even agree on that is that because
of like taiwan and taiwan's a good
example yeah so um
so
the best way i can put it to you is that
if a government wants you from an
informational point of view once you get
into your phone
they have you uh these systems are
extraordinarily robust powerful as i
learned more and more about them it's
not actually my area of expertise cyber
security but as i had to learn more
about it
for myself and for clients
when the saudis wanted to get into a
phone they could what if you're dealing
what if you're communicating rather only
through direct
encryption devices or
applications rather like signal yeah
it's a very good question so if signal
uh encrypts the the package going back
and forth between the two devices over
the internet so if you have uh
interception between device a and device
b
it'll be encrypted and but that's not
what happens with things like pegasus 2.
pegasus 2 is a very high end
system and it's in your phone
just like you're in your phone
everything you can do on your phone i
can do from 7 000 miles away in some
saudi government office wow and so
signal doesn't help you with that i do
think however
by the way signal is a is a foundation
it's not a for-profit company so i'm
glad to to promote it i do think they
have something very valuable on signal
and that is disappearing messages which
is you can if you and i were exchanging
signal communications we could set in
one week make all this disappear in one
hour make all this disappear up to four
weeks that's very valuable because
otherwise our text messages look
i i was tasked to do this for myself
when the saudi thing started which is i
have to think about everything that's on
my phone holy [ __ ]
every communication i had you know for
years every text i sent every photo
every argument every
joke that would be taken out of context
you know it's a very hard thing to do
because we're it's we're like a mind
we're collecting all of this data right
in the phone and so signal is valuable i
think signal's a good a good service and
uh but it doesn't solve the problem if a
government wants you uh if a government
wants information uh they
they can get it through programs like uh
like uh pegasus too right well how does
pegasus 2 get on your phone
well different ways it is a no-click uh
incursion meaning you don't have to
click on anything uh you you might you
know typically you would get a text and
you would open that text and that would
download the little executable file or
you would watch a video and it would be
in the video but
now the newest uh pegasus systems they
don't even need you to do anything uh
they can send you a message on whatsapp
and even if you never even if you delete
it even if you never open it they can
get in your phone what if you don't use
whatsapp
it's a help by the way i i don't
recommend whatsapp why is that
because whatsapp has had a um
for some reasons that i don't want to
share and for some reasons that i do
want to share whatsapp has had a
particularly uh vulnerable circumstance
with regard to uh with regard to uh
people getting into other people's
phones now having said that
there are thousands of people right now
all over the world working on nothing
but getting into the new iphone
operating system and then there's
thousands of people at apple working on
nothing but being sure that the new
operating system is impenetrable and
this just is a you know is an arms race
that's going to go on
it's going to go on forever so you you
were saying that don't
if you get a message through whatsapp
but what if you don't get a message
through whatsapp is that executable if
just a blank text message comes your way
and you don't open it less than that
unfortunately you can get nothing at all
with pegasus 2 you can get nothing at
all they can enter a telephone number
and they can get into your phone nothing
at all no text messages so you have no
idea whatsoever that's correct and
that's a problem with you know zero day
exploits which is you don't know what
happened and you go on for months and
months and months not knowing that
somebody's in your phone uh is a is a
problem and how do you find out if
someone's in your phone well depends on
on the circumstance in in
in the case you described uh i was
notified by originally by somebody in
cia then notified uh eight times by the
fbi about the what information they had
learned and then we began to do uh to do
uh you know work on the phone itself and
you learn about it in those ways which
is very difficult by the way because
pegasus too i feel like i'm giving a
commercial for pegasus too but
most people can't really can't buy it
anyway but pegasus 2 is not sitting in
an armchair waiting for you to arrive
hey i'm over here it is extremely well
hidden uh right down at the very core
levels of a of a phone or or an ipad
and uh
but there are strategies for uh for
finding it and they're challenging and
they're evolving all the time there are
you know whole organizations like uh
citizen lab and a and a really great
expert anthony ferrante who used to work
for obama at the white house on this
kind of stuff he's now in private
practice
they've had a lot of success they even
have found uh
pegasus ii in the wild meaning before
there was a reason to be suspicious
they've identified it and uh it's a
tricky game because it
let's say you were targeted by the
mexican government which happened a lot
to people
and
you you have it on your phone and you
think you are being monitored in some
ways so you get rid of your phone you
turn it off you put it in the top drawer
well pegasus will say hey this
activity has just stopped self-delete
it'll self-destruct
so now you you don't even have any
evidence that it ever happened even if
you could get an fbi involved so pegasus
sends a signal to the person that's
using the spyware to tell you that that
phone is not active any longer well they
know they they see immediately hey joe
isn't texting his friends anymore so
they know that right away so they
execute it independently nope it can
happen internally because what happens
remember when it's when it's turned off
or the battery is taken out or a wide
variety of things can happen
that uh you know with a quote
uh suspect phone
it will self-destruct on its own
after a few days of no contact that's
one of the things they market i got all
their marketing material uh and at the
time you know when we were really doing
this investigation we were getting a lot
of content from around the world it is
uh
it's sold by a company called nso which
is in israel based in israel and uh it's
a very dark game all over the world uh
involving governments and other powerful
people and uh you know pho
most people say well what do i care
nobody wants to get into my phone and
they're right
but if you are a person who is subject
to uh to the interest of government
anywhere in the world uh it's very hard
to have privacy so if you don't get a
message through whatsapp what are the
other vulnerabilities like could you get
a message through twitter can you get a
message yes you could get a regular
instagram you could get a regular text a
regular text pegasus one which did
require that the user click on something
but pegasus 2 is a no-click exploit
nothing has to happen
so
someone can just send you a text you
don't even have to open it not even send
you less than that what i'm saying is
that
the high-end pegasus system that's used
by saudi arabia and other countries
all they need to do is have your phone
number that's it nothing more so they
have your phone number they have access
to all your photographs your messages
everything turn on your phone as a
microphone right now in this room turn
on your phone as a camera right now and
even it's so it's so smart let's say it
makes an audio uh recording of a phone
call
and it doesn't download it right now it
waits until the phone is quiet and it's
you know late night in in the target
destination like in your home it's late
night and then it downloads it at night
so that you don't even see a reduction
in performance right and then people who
are sort of watching the the cost don't
see spikes of all kinds of activity in
the case you talked about uh gigabytes
of data was taken out of that phone
gigabytes yeah how many gigabytes are on
the phone no idea
i don't know uh so
so anyway yeah the the the short punch
line on this is that there is no way to
there's a lot of products being sold
that do the best they can but depending
on who wants you there really is no way
uh you know if the central intelligence
agency wants to get into somebody's
phone overseas they can do it now is
there a difference between operating
systems like is there more of a
vulnerability to android than there is
to iphone
i hear again not an expert but i hear
that there's more vulnerability to uh to
iphone but that might be because they
are the ones that are targeted most
often and that thousands of people are
working on all the time yeah that was my
question like what about one of those uh
de-googled android phones that are
becoming more probably better but i
don't know you don't know
because there's a lot of people that are
swearing by those now that have moved to
these operating systems that have been
manipulated to the point where they
don't send information you can't get
tracked gps doesn't work
all that stuff yeah it's good to have
the you know the least the the lowest
number of apps you can have on a phone
the better if you're talking about just
using it for phone calls the challenge i
have because i get you can imagine every
product is brought to me usually given
to me for free to try hoping that
clients will want it or that my company
will want it i see everything but the
challenge is it's a moving target so if
somebody says today oh we've got
something great for such and such two
weeks later
people have been able adversaries have
been able to work on it and it's an arms
race and so it's sort of like saying hey
i got this great new thing you know a
catapult and i can throw fiery bombs
over the wall of the castle that's not
so interesting anymore now that we have
tanks
these things continue to evolve
do you anticipate there ever being a
time where they can circumvent that and
there will no longer be exploits like
that or is this just a new reality that
people have to live with
i anticipated going in the other
direction which is that it it becomes
far more accessible for far more people
and that anything we do you know online
is is subject to
to being intercepted and seen more and
more you know a lot of people like i
have clients who could be targeted by
china could be targeted by russia could
be targeted by france could be targeted
by the united states by other companies
by powerful adversaries and they often
say well i just treat every
communication as if it could be heard uh
but the reality is that as human beings
on a phone call
we are unguarded right you don't want to
have a phone call with me or a
conversation that's that's completely
guarded
like this all the time and so the
reality is that this is going to be a
vulnerability in in people's lives uh
period and it's going to expand expand
sure and do you think it's going to
expand to the point where
regular people have access to everyone
else's phone in all their data i think
it will expand to where uh motivated
people and not governments could get
access to other people's data and you
know there are even laws uh there's some
in the uk where you know why should
people be able to have a secret
encrypted communication what are they
trying to hide
government is challenged by it right
yeah i've seen those people in power are
challenged by that stuff and so
well because we we might want to have a
communication that the government isn't
part of that would be the reason but uh
but people in power don't like it and so
slowly it will erode that way as well